in his mind we're the good guys
everything we say he interprets that way
if you say you don't care if he lives or
dies
it must be your dry gallows humor
seriously
yep that's a really stupid way to go
through life it's how most people do
then most people are really stupid and
yet we made it to the stars peaches said
amos stretched out his arms the muscles
across his shoulders hurting pleasantly
you know peaches it's nice how he got
all this help and stuff but i kind of
liked it better when it was only you and
me
you say the sweetest things i'm gonna
track down some coffee or tea
or amphetamines you need anything nope
i'm solid
he watched her walk away she was still
way too thin but since he'd stepped into
the room in the pit at bethlehem
she'd taken on a kind of confidence he
wondered if she had to go back whether
she still wanted him to kill her
probably something worth asking about
hey guys pete here
time to break down season 5 episode 9 of
the expanse
the end is near and winnipesaki
concludes one of the major storylines
while inching everything else right to
the edge it had a bit of everything with
a sad moment from the once in future
queen
and some displays of that characteristic
belter endurance and resilience from
naomi and drummer
i mean i know growing up a belter has
prepared drummer to function with a boot
on her neck but coral really feels like
she's pushing her luck at this point
before we get into it this is your
spoiler warning
if you haven't watched season 5 episode
9 yet then this video won't be for you
you need to go get caught up first and
then come back and watch i will be
referring to the books as someone who's
read them but won't be revealing any
future spoilers from those
with that out of the way let's get
started at the end of episode 8 naomi
was able to alter the chatsmoka's fake
distress call that was playing on a loop
before she cut it off
it was a hail mary move and probably
just about the only thing she could have
done under the circumstances
that episode came to an end with coral
and oksana hearing the message and in
the beginning of episode 9 we see the
message getting out everywhere else
i liked how we saw the different
reactions all together here marco has
the most information about what's
happening
and he figures out right away that naomi
isn't dead
alex and bobby noticed the message
changed before it stopped transmitting
but aren't sure what to make of that
holden and the rossi are pretty much in
the same boat but i guess since bull
isn't crew
he seems to take every chance they give
him to buck against helping out naomi
i'm not sure if there's something else
there but it feels funny at this point
either way he dials it back both ships
are now making their way towards the
chet's mocha
and we know that the razorback is going
to make it there first
naomi's still there trying to find a way
to protect her family from falling into
marco's trap she's still taking trips
out into the vacuum between the halls
and she finds some ice there on the
outside of some pipes
she's able to scrape some of that off
onto her wrist display and get some much
needed water
she half collapses to the floor and she
notices one of the wires to the
explosive devices
is nicked at the end of the episode we
see that she's able to connect that to
the display on the face shield of one of
the helmets
she gets a quick burst of relief when
she notices that the screaming fire hawk
is getting closer to where she's at
remember the message she received from
alex in the last episode
he told her the razorback was flying
under that name
so she knows this is alex and bobby but
she can also see the display that shows
when the explosives will arm and when
they will detonate
there is a problem she has to warn them
and we see her go back
out and hear a banging noise considering
that she scraped the ice off of some
pipes and we saw her look at her wrist
display before she went out
i'm guessing that she's beating on those
pipes having read the books i have a
pretty good idea of why she's doing that
but i'll just leave it there for now
on luna we check in with avasarala who's
looking at a monument of names of people
who died as a result of the asteroid
attack
from a monitor nearby she learns that
pastor moved forward with the plan to
strike palestinian
they kept her out of the loop on that so
she finds delgado and gives him the
business
in the cabinet room the military and the
secretary general are discussing
follow-up strikes
avasarala tries to talk them out of
further escalation
she's making the same case she was
making originally and it still makes a
lot of sense
but you can see that as she's talking
she realizes that nobody's listening to
her and that's the reason why they cut
her out of the decision in the first
place
she asked if marco is their role model
now and it all builds to an emotional
speech
where she breaks down about losing her
husband talks about how she wants
revenge of course she does
but then points out that everyone who
lost someone on palace feels the exact
same way
the secretary general who's obviously
getting into this
getting riled up deflects the un's
military might
tries to tell her that they can't let
emotions decide
it's pretty wild they move on to plans
about attacking series station where
millions of people
live including a lot of kids and
families
they mentioned that anderson dawes is an
ally and they just sort of brush that
aside saying that they don't trust them
anyways
and at that point abasarala has had all
she can take
and she resigns with a handful of other
cabinet members following her lead
later we see that now that she said it
out loud she's accepted that arjun is
dead
she adds his name to the memorial in a
scene that really hit me harder than i
was expecting
the dedication reads if life transcends
death then i will search for you there
and this is from a poem that arjun wrote
for her that was a really great moment
in the second book
and the rest of it says if not then
there too
this is also a nice easter egg for
something that'll happen later in the
books which i can't say
but book readers know what i'm talking
about while she's there she's approached
by one of the cabinet members
who tells her that other cabinet members
are walking away from pastor and he's
gonna get a vote of no confidence
they're approaching her to be his
replacement and after accepting she goes
to see delgado in his office
to ask him if he'll join her cabinet and
after he declines saying that he wants
to join a strike force and go after
marco hopefully he'll be the guy who
kills marco
we get the end of the joke which turns
out not to be very funny but fitting for
the situation
the punchline is the earther asks for
the best belter liquor they have and
when the bartender asks because you're
trying to drink like your enemy
he says no because i'm trying to drink
less and the best the belt has to offer
is terrible basically earthers looking
at belters as next to nothing
and certainly not enough to be their
enemies delgado adds at the end that it
used to be funnier and while he probably
believed that you see it hid in him that
you know it kind of really wasn't the
big thing here is abasarala is now
in charge which should be to the un's
advantage and rip arjun
it is a sad situation especially when
you think about how things ended with
them avasarala never had a chance to
reconcile after what happened in the
last season
we catch up with drummer's faction all
three of her ships are docked together
we find carl and oksana looking for
privacy on the dewalt
they take a look at the chet's mocha and
see that it hasn't changed course
so they know that even if naomi is alive
that she doesn't have control of the
ship
based on what drummers told her about
naomi oksana thinks this may not last
and that drummer will definitely want to
investigate when she finds out so carol
tells her she can't say anything
she makes a not so subtle threat here
that drummer isn't the only person that
oxana loves in their crew
and that they all pledge their lives the
whole crew the whole faction to marco
and naros
and there will be consequences for all
of them she says he knows about the
situation
and he'll give them orders a little bit
later we find out what he wants them to
do
he wants the drummer faction to go meet
up with the cereal mall
and the koto and he wants them to hunt
down and destroy the rasanante
this doesn't make any sense to drummer
because the story is that the ross ante
is going into a trap and is going to be
destroyed anyways the question is why
take the risk
crawl says that they want to show the
free navy taking out a symbol
of assimilation and compromise and while
this doesn't really convince
drummer another not-so-subtle threat
gets drummer to agree to go along if
that's what needs to be done
of course marco and carol know naomi is
alive and that's why they don't want to
leave things to chance
oksana also knows and she goes to
drummer and gets her to hand over her
gun
because she fears that she might just
lose it and kill coral
and that would put serge's life in
danger later these two come together and
drummer knows oxana is keeping something
from her it's a pretty powerful exchange
where drummer tells it like she sees it
everything she's done to this point with
the free navy has been about her family
and now she thinks that oksana doesn't
respect her enough to tell her the truth
oksana asks her if she loves the family
as much as she loves naomi
drummer's hurt by this but oxana says
she needs to hear her say it which she
does
then she tells her that naomi might
still be alive but that she can't go
save her because they know what happened
to the factions that went against him
for now they're stuck and it looks like
they're gonna have to try to hunt down
the ross
ante as oxana said it's five ships
against one so they shouldn't really
have a problem there but we'll have to
wait and see what happens
on top of ordering them to do that marco
does go and talk to philip and explain
to him that naomi survived
he uses this to make his son feel
abandoned again he completely
manipulates him with the situation
he tells him that she didn't walk out of
the ship in desperation
she did it to escape she left us she
left both of us
again and when he hears that philip
flips out and you have to feel for him a
bit in this situation
because the show didn't really show her
planning this it didn't lean into the
idea that she had to make the decision
knowing that this may happen to philip
essentially she had to choose her new
family the family that she
chose the crew of the rasanante over her
own child
of course marco put her in that
situation and then seeing him use that
against philip really underlines what
kind of character he is
for the final part of the story we see
amos clarissa eric and their crew
arrive at winnipesaukee it looks pretty
deserted there
they fly in it looks like they brought
about a dozen of eric's henchmen with
them
and they're heavily armed they find the
hanger in the launch pad and clarissa
says that she can fly the shuttle
they discover the winter staff hiding
there they remember clarissa and her
family
and they tell them that the shuttle
hasn't flown for a couple of years and
they think there's a problem with the
reactor
some staff from the other houses show up
because they saw the helicopter
they basically been abandoned eric and
amos instantly tell them to get lost
they're not there to help them but
clarissa says that they can come along
if they want to
eric objects and this causes a riff amos
can see where he's coming from but
decides to side with clarissa
perhaps thinking that this is the kind
of thing holden would do
while they continue to work on the
shuttle they're interrupted by a private
security team
who comes to the property and wants to
take their food and supplies to a
central location
eric and amos see this for what it is
it's a shakedown and they're not even
doing a good job of it
and tensions escalate until guns are
drawn once again clarissa jumps in
and tries to de-escalate but this is a
very different situation
and while amos sides with her again just
telling them to walk away
he does so knowing that these people are
gonna come back
everybody knows they're gonna come back
so they're hoping they can fix the
shuttle and be gone by the time that
happens
it's an interesting contrast where you
have these two characters i just did the
big amos and clarissa video the other
day where i talked about how they
complement each other
and part of why they work so well
together is that they're both bringing
different things to the table in this
journey to try to be something better
here we get an example where this
transformation is an ongoing process
and there's going to be some mistakes
made because decisions like these don't
fall neatly
into moral categories a little bit later
in the shuttle's cockpit peaches and
eric talk and i really enjoyed this
they have a little back and forth he
asked why timmy calls her peaches
and she admits that she doesn't know why
she asks why he calls him timmy
because that's his name but she doesn't
know that and she says should i ask and
he says
i wouldn't she starts talking about
tribes and veers into kumbaya territory
talking about maybe if we let everyone
in our tribe no one would have thrown
rocks at us in the first place
eric kind of rolls his eyes to this and
says jesus where did timmy find you
and she says serving a life sentence for
multiple homicides
amos goes outside to think a bit because
you can't figure out what's going on
with the ship
he has a conversation there with one of
the henchmen hut says i guess the last
time you left you were happy to go
and amos says no not at first and when
asked what changed he said he found his
place
hutch says that they spent their whole
life learning how to survive in
baltimore
and there's apprehension there about
leaving it behind even though it's not
much
amos makes the point that no one really
starts over because no one really leaves
anything behind
and this further reinforces his
revelation that he had in episode six
where he realized that he needed to get
back to his crew
he had to come back to earth to find out
what happened to lydia he's done that
and now he can leave knowing that
there's nothing left for him there
that his real home is on the rossignante
they're able to fix the shuttle but the
security guards come back
a shootout happens and i enjoyed this
even though i knew the outcome
i still found it exciting to watch
several of eric's guys get taken out
while clarissa is getting all the staff
on board she hears some of the security
guards coming in the other entrance
she's able to use her mods to kill all
of them and that makes a pretty big
impression with eric he says he's gonna
be a lot nicer to her from now on
he's seen the kumbaya side now he's seen
the other
amos gets wounded hutch saves him then
when they're getting on the ship the
tables are turned
and amos saves hutch they make it on
board amos tells them to go and while
the hangar doors are still opening up
eric decides to light up the epstein
drive
and that slags the entire area including
the house
and all the security guards go up in
smoke this is fun to see because it's
something they consider doing with their
drives at various points in the book and
now i understand what that would
actually look like
it looks like hutch survived and it
looks like they'll be able to make it to
luna
they'll have some stuff to figure out
when they get there i suppose
and we'll see how that goes next week
this was pretty much what i expected so
i was pretty happy with the episode
it finishes off amos's journey to earth
avasarala is back in charge
and the razorback and ross ante are both
heading towards naomi
so that's pretty much everything that
had to happen the drummer stuff
is pretty intense and it's hard to see
how she can get out of that situation
without killing karol
it seemed pretty unlikely considering
there's no doubt that marco will space
surge in retaliation but i'm having
trouble thinking of a different outcome
she could leave the family but then
she'll probably be hunted down herself
so i don't know let me know if you see a
future where drummer learns to play nice
with the free navy because they aren't
making it easy
the avasarala scenes were interesting
and her saying goodbye to arjun had some
weight to it
i really enjoyed seeing amos torn
between his old ways of thinking and the
new
and how having eric and clarissa there
served to pull him in different
directions where there were no easy
decisions
that seems like a pretty good place to
leave things i'll talk about where
things might be going in my preview
video which will come out in a few days
let me know in the comments what you're
thinking what you thought of this
episode what you think's gonna happen in
the finale
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon